[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Волинь,
Повча]
— Після життя в місті нічого...
— Нам нічого не бракує.
— Зовсім нічого.
— Оце порівняння...
[Дмитро Радчук
Співзасновник агросадиби «Хутір Касень»]
... цієї природи, свіжого повітря, цієї тиші і спокою.
Із заторами, із такими невідомими речами,
про які забули і від яких відвикли.
Була мрія займатися вівчарством.
Шукали місце, де є вільне пасовище,
так побачили тут,
сподобалось, вирішили спробувати.
У нас на сьогодні 72 голови.
Починали з невеликого стада, купили 10 вівць.
Вийшло, подумали чому б не взяти більше.
Докупили ще 40 і таким чином
почали розвивати стадо.
Ми займаємось овітерапією.
Овітерапія — це вживання, користування
і спілкування з твариною, з овечкою.
[Вікторія Радчук
Співзасновниця агросадиби «Хутір Касень»]
Тому в нас є маленькі ягнята,
з ними можна поспілкуватися.
Те, що ми готуємо, можна спробувати,
тому в нас повний процес овітерапії.
Тільки в процесі спілкування
мовчить, не говорить нічого.
[сміється]
Нашій садибі цього року, 1 червня, було два роки.
Це третій рік ми займаємося зеленим туризмом.
Найманих працівників у нас немає.
Ми намагаємося самі, але інколи
звертаємося по допомогу до друзів.
Робимо екскурсії, дитячі зимові свята,
басейн, трав'яний чай варимо,
вирощуємо трави.
Щодо харчування:
здебільшого ми пропонуємо баранину.
Готуємо, оскільки Дмитро у нас технолог
по харчуванню, на садибі він усе готує.
Маємо музеї на нашій території,
збираємо старовинні речі.
Люди нам приносять багато або щось купуємо.
Це в нас тераса в українському стилі.
Це, до речі, у нас ще є одна старовинна
хата, вона трішки далі.
Там жила людина, ось це повністю всі
меблі він зробив своїми руками.
Оці такі ручні валізки, це все в нас таке.
Ось це, до речі, ножиці, що нам подарували,
щоб стригти вівці руками.
Самі ми з Луцька,
моє коріння з Рівненської області,
а переїжджати десь далеко не хотілося.
Ми займалися підприємством,
підприємницькою діяльністю,
а потім це в принципі теж закінчили
і вирішили присвятити себе своїй мрії.
Тут саме нікого і не було, тут ніхто не жив.
Ми знайшли власників, купили ці землі,
які можна було тут узяти.
Перші наші кроки: ми взяли
таку армійську палатку, намет,
розклали його і почали...
Дістали пили і пішли все тут різати.
Тут заросло взагалі все повністю,
трава, сухостій, стояли вище голови.
Старі садки позаростали,
тут хащі були, пройти не можна.
— Тут було все в золотарнику.
— Такі джунглі.
Тут стояла одна хатинка стара,
ми її переробили.
Те, що ціле, залишили на місці.
Доліпили, зробили баню.
І так поступово-поступово.
Спочатку баня, потім кімнати,
потім тераса, потім піч.
Зі старого хутора зробили агросадибу.
Найближчі сусіди, які в нас були,
жили два чоловіка, то вони вже й померли,
їх уже нема, ні одного, ні другого.
І так само та хата стоїть, так само
чекає свого нового господаря.
Якщо вірити легендам,
цьому хутору десь років чотириста.
Тут були, свого часу, приблизно 40 дворів.
Тут жили чехи, і німці, і поляки.
Потрохи люди почали виїжджати і,
у такий спосіб, хутір став занепадати.
Взагалі, ще при Союзі тут у селі була вівцеферма.
Тому вівчарство тут було, і ми
хочемо відроджувати цю галузь.
Мені подобається ця місцевість, подобається хутір.
Є дуже багато своїх ідей, і хотілося б,
щоб цей хутір відродився і жив.
Щоб сюди повернулась молодь, повернулись
люди і почали тут працювати.
В нас немає ніяких сумнівів,
ми абсолютно в стані драйву.
[сміється]
Звичайно, фермерство це дуже важко,
але дійсно, кожного разу це позитив, енергія.
І коли тобі подобається те, що ти робиш.
Ми бачимо, оскільки до нас приїжджають люди,
їм це дійсно подобається,
вони відпочивають,
вони підзаряджаються якоюсь енергією.
Може, цього місця, нашою працею.
Це дійсно дуже круто.
Поки що батарейка наша не сіла.
Я надіюсь що буде далі,
ми будемо далі цим займатися.
Важко, але це дуже цікаво.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Sasha Boole]
[Субтитрувальниця
Уляна Супрунюк]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]